quand je suis très fatigué je suis
anxieuse fait que je me mets à penser
que tout le monde va bien selon moi fait
que je me sens très seul à ce moment là
les fois je laime solitude ou des fois
je l'impôt un mot sur les entraves à la
mobilité qui fera en sorte d' accentuer
mon sentiment de solitude
habitué à vivre seul
saissac et dreux
[Musique]
l'impro décembre 2016 je suis partie de
montréal pour m'amener ici à ces êtres
qui dure pourrait dans un logement
social et qui permettait d'avoir des
services de soutien des missions de nuit
qu ce que je n'aurais pu dans les mêmes
délits notamment à montréal c'est de
nous n'est pas parce que au niveau du
transport débit je suis pas capable de
livrer ma famille ou mes amis à montréal
ou des chats ma femme ma conjointe j'ai
tombé de cheval
en plus j'ai regagné ma vie j'ai quitté
la campagne puis je me suis retrouvé
seul à vivre à montréal achète un
appartement à 17 ans oui j'avais l'aide
de mes parents m'aient asseyez survivant
présumé ce collège klein
[Musique]
la vérité où brille ça me rend triste
mais j'essaye d'en parler c'est je me
dis jean-paul des puncheurs comme sûr je
connais une femme de 89 ans avicii comme
parce que ça pouvait domaine à 89 ans je
ne sais pas mais je vous envoie 75 puis
je trouve ça dur la chaudière qui
commençait à prendre des substances pour
essayer de déteindre cette émotion locke
qui était pas capable de gérer la après
la drogue fini de faire et fait encore
plus ensuite un gros plus triste pas sa
soeur avec le discontinu prendre la
drogue
le ca devien service yeux puis tout ce
que tu fais cette isolé des autres des
jo car période non l'hivernale je suis
limité dans les déplacements
ça devient en période hivernale atroce
je ne s'en pose qui fait que parfois
dans la jeunesse
j'ai connu un ce qu'on appelait des
périodes de découragement hivernale où à
force de pouvoir personne à part
peut-être ce qui donne des soins
tu viens qu'à trouver selon en mousse
si j'avais mes deux jambes je pouvais
pas le boss au terminus meurent en amont
rien vaquer à mes occupations pour venir
la seconde
pourquoi parce que je suis différent
j'ai autant d entraves dans la mobilité
et qu'on ségalen qu'on l'absence du
monde cela de solitude pourquoi quand je
suis ici
quand j'étais en voyage quand j'entends
châssis quand je vois deux des musées
qu'elle venait trop ceci je pensais je
pense pas à ces choses là c'est là
samedi et dimanche que je trouve ça dur
le samedi dimanche suite seul dans mon
âge
je paye on me pour le père est le
sentiment de solitude si tu penses que
c'est les autres qui donne un sens à ta
vie je me suis rendu compte que c'est
moi qui donne un sens à ma vie
donc oui des fois je me sens seule mais
je ne me laisse pas envahir par ce
sentiment là j'essaie de me changer les
idées gens ne s'en sort pas pareil je
veux je peux être anéantie parce que
jamais prince aux emprunts des habitants
près des communications centre est du
social 130 prédit t'aimera toujours on
cherche des moyens de de long seulement
rallume un bisou mais on cherche tous
les moyens pour faire en sorte de ne pas
engorger les urgences
or un des moyens c'est de faire en sorte
que les gens ressentent moins solitude
dans la maison qu'ils seront mieux
supporter new wave compagnie va toujours
des gens seuls puis les allemands mais
je pense que on pourrait en parler plus
parce que ça l'aiderait à prendre
conscience à la société puis c'est un
str et puis créer un dialogue entre les
personnes seules les personnes qui sont
pas plus qu'ils sont prêts à aider